greetings mug Club let's take a journey
I
know
[Music]
and I was never suspected
you can travel the world and see the
third world's close
[Applause]
[Music]
up
let you know
for freaks into deep power outage
warning on the stereo
[Music]
comes first you'll be falling apart
[Applause]
we'll take your testicle
[Music]
[Applause]
now put your hands up
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
delicious hey glad to be with you uh
today you know every now I'm just gonna
hey everyone give a round of applause to
the people here who work really hard
never watch myself but uh when it's uh
when it's Riley uh in the video everyone
here watches yes stop that she's a
married lady and she is fantastic her
face sniffing the cocaine and that was
way
anyway every now and then I get to sit
back and enjoy uh this and uh we're so
grateful that to all of you support us
this doesn't just doesn't come uh we're
not running this on a Disney budget so
again it's the free mug Club month live
with credit.com if you want to see more
like that hey do consider joining we try
to give you more bang for your buck all
right we have a lot to get to today
uh uh we're gonna be talking about you
know what code switching is are you
aware of that code switching is when
people with the left is created as a
term meaning people who do voices uh so
it's like black face but black voice uh
you know I I've done some code switching
but people who do it genuinely uh we
have it we have AOC yeah we have of
course this new representative who was
ousted and then back in we have Joe
Biden we have Kamala Harris We'll be
talking about that the left does this
only it's not a joke and we'll also be
talking about look this is a big win uh
I don't believe necessarily the go woke
go broke comment below if you think
that's something that is true my
headphones are a little bit loud here
today uh
maybe to interview the uh somebody to
say former president some people say
sitting president I say sitting
president okay so a lot going on behind
the scenes but uh the Bud Light thing
they've lost a lot of money okay now it
isn't about money for them it's about
mitigating their ESG uh risk so that
they can really sort of uh you know
attract Investments but
these are two different worlds and guess
what what you're doing is working you
need to celebrate the wins where you can
get them and I'd love to hear what it is
that you guys are drinking and we'll
offer some solutions uh for for people
out there when these situations arise
this is what we try and do here a lot of
people will say hey I feel kind of
helpless okay this is happening but it's
so large it starts locally but there are
things that you six billion dollars is
not a mundane detail Michael we'll be
talking about that as well as black
maternal Health week because
it's a thing Gerald a CEO how are you
I'm doing well how are you I'm good I'm
just a little little tired yeah it's the
end of the week it's that red time well
it's not now I also found out I was
inadvertently exposed to cats how does
that happen I'll explain later they're
everywhere someone's trying to poison
Dory there
and then in third chair oh that's right
you're the only one who doesn't know the
story in the third chair we have uh you
know him you love them actually we have
third and fourth year we have uh Brian
Callan and Pops Crowder Brian cow is
going to be in Portland April 20th
through the 22nd the rest of us this is
come on those tickets are going so fast
it's called the Crowder effect kids all
right so if we weren't able to add an
extra show in Portland oh so you might
add an extra show but you can catch me
at the vasani theater and uh go to
briancount.com and see all the tour
dates too because there are a lot of
Tours there and uh same thing by the way
Nick depalo's show is here on mug club
now you can watch this show every day
Monday through Friday actually on mug
Club Monday through Thursday on rumble
or YouTube at 10 A.M Eastern uh can we
bring it up 10 a.m Eastern uh and then
you can watch Nick depaolo the soothing
voices of Nick de Paul
you know what we need to do we need to
do I've been listening to bedtime
stories lately like in audio books oh
what do you have Nick de Paulo too
bedtime story that's a good idea guided
meditation all right I don't know you're
arms probably from the tents loosen it
I bet Nick de Paul Humpty Dumpty bang
your head against a wall yes without
that bed I swear get out of that bed oh
my gosh please oh oh you're whining
about that someone in his mouth so we
can go to bed I just go to sleep already
on rubber sheets
go to sleep yeah I don't know well I
don't know what you want divisions of
sugar chicks with dancing in your head
okay all right
the funny is he's so sweet all right so
we have a lot to get to uh and I'm
excited it's a fun show and uh by the
way we'll be testing uh today on mug
club uh Casey's gag reflex if you notice
it yeah because I was really upset he's
a very very slight gag he's a very
fragile gag reflex we're not doing
anything gross just so you know nothing
from not doing anything gross we are
going to anticipating it that that whole
row that robust Row the Tim looks like a
wood Gypsy he looks like he knows the
difference between trees right I mean
I'm not entirely sure what Gypsy means I
don't either but I think there's a
connoisseur of wood he looks like he
yeah he looks like uh he he just stepped
out of the Civil War and he he knows how
to he knows how to work his hands yes
he really is Handy that's what we hear
he built his own pergola his own smoker
he makes his own beer the soap we have
here is from Tool Man he's like yeah
rotten soap I'm like why is this soap
why is it so why is it
is it's coffee beans in there for more
effective exfoliation I'm like how do
you have time
how's the guy the gangrene Tim you're
not gonna knock off those toes I don't
know why I'm speaking back I'm from
Ireland well you're code switching
but I wouldn't go to him for questions
on literature no oh all right
sorry we're off top wisdom let's get
back to time we have a lot to cover so
before we get to that Abercrombie is uh
is back I never knew that they went away
I thought Fitch was gone Abercrombie did
you remember that do you guys know this
comment below Abercrombie and Fitch
started out as a homeowner gun catalog
yeah
long time we did a story on it yep and
it's a far cry from that because now
they're back in the spotlight with their
new advertising campaign and uh this one
is definitely not a father teaching his
son how to hunt
[Music]
wow that looks like George Michael
here's the irony they just accidentally
created the most heterosexual thing ever
that's right they're both like we're
gender but then they're just too
straight yeah they can totally reproduce
yes you gotta say that I just that just
makes me want to release doves yeah
celebrate my opportunity yeah it makes
me want to uh kill the doves yeah they
used to compete with Orvis for the
lesbian Market they were all plaid yeah
for a year oh yeah that was plaid it was
Guns it was yeah but that that looks
that sleeves on the on the Blazer that
looks like George Michael is uh banging
uh Jimmy uh Snuka
or Samoa Joe one of those Samoans I
don't know
the point is it is gross but hey
whatever sells more shitty sweaters it
won't that's the problem I know it won't
yeah I don't know I don't it doesn't
make me want to run out and buy remember
a halter top remember when they
sleeveless halter remember when they uh
used to want to like Market Beautiful
People yes yes that was a thing remember
like models were supposed they were
beautiful they were good the biggest
compliment I ever received I was in uh
uh I was in Simi Valley or Van Nuys at
one of those outdoor malls and this is I
think I might have been 19 and I was on
a date this person came up said hey
excuse me I would like to know would you
like to work uh over there for us at
Abercrombie I said oh no but thank you
nope I got offered to be a barker once
did you yeah at a circus that's your
weight I don't have your uh I don't have
your your morning Brian yeah not at all
I was actually a barker as well hey
let's move on to code switching here uh
it's a live show Monday through Friday
10 a.m Eastern if you're on YouTube
right now also please comment like
because as you're there well yeah but
comment likes so people know that they
can head on over to rumble yeah because
YouTube as you can see through the
algorithms you can search this show you
can search the title and you won't find
it so let's go to Martin Luther cringe
uh
it's just a good the Tennessee
representative Justin Pearson and I have
to read that because I don't care about
him
[Music]
he was reinstated uh to the state house
after being expelled for being a dick
now uh to celebrate his return these
people are just I'm sorry ad hominem
sure scum yes also losers yes dweebs yes
so let's celebrate his return now and
educate you on not just uh Mr Pearson
but uh all of the Democrat politicians
who engage in code switching with a then
and now
thank you
it's so nice being demonetized because
it is you can just have the you can just
have the uh the the the what's I just
want to say System of a Down
and say that yes
all right so here if you may not you may
not know this here is Pearson uh so I'm
gonna spoiler alert okay because you
can't get away with it we can't get away
with it uh uh uh Hank Azaria can't get
away with it doing the voice of a poo in
a cartoon but this man uh can get away
with entirely faking a black accent he's
like the representative equivalent of
Drake a butter soft from a white
Jewish area of Toronto who sounds like
he's from Memphis also by the way here's
how I know you're a Drake your
first lyrics are like a like a sprained
ankle ain't nothing to play with you
couldn't think of anything more severe
yeah you play you
[Laughter]
anti-inflammatories to be productive in
the morning gotta be well rested yeah
mother you heard what I just said
shout out to John I went to high school
with his brother all right so uh here is
Pearson representative Pearson running
for class uh president uh in college in
2016. this is what he sounded like that
hey everybody I'm Justin J Pearson and
I'm running for president of BSG there
are a few reasons
one has to do with representation how
can we represent all voices in a
conversation
Democrats to the Boon Republicans I want
to bring together different voices
dissenting voices voices I mean the ones
in your head
my grandmother he's such a nice color
for conversations
no yeah you can you can say people of
color and that brings us to now hmm and
this is like if you're on children's
placemats you know it's like hey spot
the six differences
also it's also like it's also like
navigate your way through the maze uh
also you might as well just tear up the
placemat and throw a hot coffee in your
lap and squirt your dick because this is
about what this segment is going to feel
like see if you can Spot the Difference
here is Pearson now celebrating his
triumphant return to the state house
yesterday
[Applause]
he's doing here if you don't
he's if you don't say Jesus's name when
you're talking this way you're you're at
risk of conjuring Spirits yes right so
Beelzebub can come up through the ground
but hopefully he conjures a spirit of a
real black guy oh well
what do you mean real black guy what do
you mean by real black guy shut up he's
doing the Sam Kinison thing right and
I'm in the state house and I want to be
here
I talk like this even though I used to
be
yeah
[Music]
wasn't he a preacher
and he told it was a it was performance
art yeah it's like professional
wrestling so here's the thing Justin the
license plate on his rolled uh Corvette
said xrev oh yeah that's right yes I bet
you Pearson has a vanity license plate
yeah it says white
you can't even read it white on white
they're like this is a violation of the
traffic codes I'm sorry officer did you
pull me over because I'm black black we
had no idea good sir this is a violation
of oh your schizophrenica we're going to
take away your license here yes well
just you know what let's just list
cataracts okay Justin Pearson is not
unique here's the thing Democrats are
Master panders hey black Americans they
hate you hey Latino Americans they hate
you hey women they actually hate they
want to see you physically beaten to a
pulp by men who claim to be women but
they claim to be more relatable right
this is what and they engage in what is
called code switching and the left is a
group that harped on code switching all
the time right that this is about like
switching and your voice and you guys
can check all the references at live
with credit.com they did the same thing
with fake news for a lot of you I know
some of you are new viewers you may not
remember the left created the term fake
news to try and get rid of alternative
media right yeah like ourselves and then
Donald Trump switched it on them and
said you're fake news they're like what
no no and then all of a sudden they got
mad and they didn't want the term fake
it's our thing that's our thing turn it
on us so it's called code switching it's
about pandering and changing your
identity and if you don't fully grasp it
yet here's an explanation from the goat
and I'll tell you something else you
probably didn't know and that is this
this is not my real speaking voice
actually Chuck this is my real speaking
voice I talk like straight up gangsta
I love Dave Chappelle it's great you
know what's funny about this is um when
I say so I've always got to keep no
everything everything is always funny
but I keep this accent to myself because
when I'm around you common people I'm
afraid I have to speak that's code
switching that's exactly I know but you
wouldn't understand me if I spoke the
queen's English Brian no no no no
it's The King's English oh yes there's
of course there's a man with a penis
that's right
now we all
have one you know what I want to do just
once as an Englishman I just want to go
like this
release the hounds right and then you'd
have to sleep with your sister yes you
have a sister under bite yes there's
nothing wrong with sleeping with you
assistant that's just an old wives tale
I have my father's eyes and my mother's
also eyes
my blood's blue you know that's how they
know you're royalty
why why such a high voice I'm the queen
of course oh you're the queen I assume
there's been some carbon D guessing on
the vehicle chords
you identify as the queen well that's
true this is not accurate I would have
had my lasered off as the result of my
horrible incestuous relations
Mr Queenie in in Canada still puts it on
their money yeah let's be more like
those people all right so code switching
as you just saw thank you for
exemplifying it Brian sure this is the
definition the ways in which a member of
an underrepresented group consciously or
unconsciously adjusts their language
syntax grammatical structure behavior
and appearance to fit into the dominant
culture so they often say it's what
black people do to become white because
it's all seen through identity Politics
as opposed to right and wrong look I
think doing voices for fun uh is fine
we've been doing it since the beginning
and beginning of time I think that
faking like you are someone else is
what's wrong but the left switches it
entirely comedy it's inappropriate we
have to fire Hank Azari who does a poo
we can't have a white guy do a black guy
voice in a cartoon but we can have
people act as though they are an
entirely different race so long as it is
uh conducive to gaining votes let me
bring you through a few examples not
just Pearson here he's the latest
example Hillary Clinton now you all know
Hillary Clinton uh you know her
yes
and you know what comment below if
you're watching uh if you're watching
live okay and if you're not watching
live pause it so there's no comment who
you think are going to be showcased as
examples here
here's Hillary Clinton he's speaking
um you know as our normal demonic self
lessons that I've learned about
getting back okay
[Laughter]
short doses yeah short doses yeah but I
don't really think it's I don't think
the the poison is in the dose I think
any dose it's it's all poison
it's like GHB it's just it's you're
immediately vomiting on the floor oh
come on yeah
he's clearly used GHP
a driving if you ask John Stamos yes
they got caught for GHB all right really
yes yes I know John I didn't know they
did drugs who cares exactly the name is
there that you dropped all right hey as
long as you get as long as you get free
or it goes for life oh I can't get a
table at your restaurant I know John
Stamos think again right like yeah he
tipped Us in the box set DVD of Full
House don't wait up
here is Hillary Rodham Clinton
pretending to be Southern
you know they've just been minding their
own business and they got hit by a new
year you know I'm not sitting here
by my man like Tammy wines called
distraught saying her life was going to
be ruined ruined ruined whether they're
living in rural Iowa or inner city New
York or anywhere else
anywhere else what is she doing a Tammy
when that impersonation I'm playing
Devil's Advocate no she wasn't there
there are more clips of that too but
here's another one for you here why
that's a natural treasure she's a here
she is pretending to be
uh as your grandmother would say colored
I don't feel no Ways Tired
my car
no body told me that the road would be
easy and not to be outdone by Daniel
Day-Lewis through method acting here she
is uh uh acting as an Inseparable
what difference at this point does it
make no which one's genuine you be the
judge none
she ended a sentence in a preposition I
think yeah well that's outrageous yeah
yeah hey Tim did you notice that her
husband is the master unforgivable
propositioning I'm coming down hard on
you today I don't know why okay it's all
about literature let's go to AOC who uh
I've said this repeatedly I can't wait
for father time to pull the rip cord so
I can despise her I do find her
attractive exterior just as much as her
insides right now I only hate her inside
which is no it's wrong to hate but I do
but I wanna I wanna I wanna date her and
I want to argue politics and then have
crazy makeup sex is that weird yeah I
hope your wife's not watching you delete
that yeah oh yeah my wife no my wife
understands yeah she understands Brian
it's a live show yeah we can't delete
anything but it's live uh trying to beat
me here's AOC and uh it's funny she does
what you do as a kind of a joke but she
was born by the way in New York okay
she spent most of her childhood in uh
the wealthy Yorktown area right of New
York and uh she is a code switching
connoisseur here she is trying to
connect with black voters again with a
fake accent I'm
[Music]
I'm ain't nothing wrong with that
there's nothing wrong with working
retailers
wrong with preparing the food that your
neighbors will eat yeah I had a
nightmare today
[Laughter]
to be judged by the content of this
here she is trying to be authentic and I
say trying because it's cute uh by
saying uh Puerto Rico uh in the way that
she thinks um you know she should say it
today represents a historic moment while
Puerto Rico is not the United States
she only pronounced Rico yes she said
Puerto Rico let's play it again are you
right you're probably right let's play
it again today represents the historic
moment while Puerto Rico is not oh my
gosh
I'm saying wonderful timing
terrible time in America exactly you
forget I'm in America
[Laughter]
let's watch the Jets try and pretend to
be straight
she's awful I put my switchblade on you
see how many people got their asses
kicked when they were being mugged
because they thought I'm not going to
give you my wallet I've seen how this
gang violence plays out whoa what do you
mean I'm just gonna do a muscle up on
that pipe
so we break out in song
officer krupke in here that's right yeah
yeah all right Jeff You're The Swinging
his thing little boy you're a man little
man you're a king yes how about that and
then riff and Tony were getting it on at
the uh convenience store exactly if
you're smiling yes what are you saying
about Spanish accents here's the thing
though so Brian she just like you do
like the karate thing okay but she's
serious and here she is pronouncing
Puerto Rico like the white person uh or
I should say the Homegrown American uh
that she is well I think what happened
in my family is what happened to
thousands of Puerto Ricans which one
which one make up
Puerto Rico
Alexandria you know how they get her to
her interviews what's that they're a
little rabbit run up to the camera
peanut butter
[Laughter]
it's one of those days uh Kamala Harris
is another example so we've got Hillary
Clinton we've got AOC code switching
yeah just keep in mind again they'll
attack you if you do a voice right
you'll have more people upset that I did
an impression of Martin Luther King Jr
poorly yes
here's that bad though who uh she's from
uh she you know Jamaican Heritage or
Indian Heritage both corrupt more Indian
I believe yeah yeah it depends on who's
who she's pandering to yes true so let's
just give her both she went to West
Mount High School in Montreal Kamala
Harris yes
anyone are you sure about that positive
she went to West Mountain yeah oh that's
a high school in Montreal for sure
it is a big it's the Highland Park of
Montreal yeah it's very very wealthy is
that right yeah West Mountain Montreal I
didn't know she went to Westmont
Montreal uh let's fact check it
otherwise but I get to admonish my dad
which is funny so here is Kamala Harris
the Jamaican part of Kamala Harris uh
trying to relate to
um Southern blacks we will tell them we
were hanging out in a
all our friends oh I loved her in the
clumsies
and here she is again remember we
provide all the references I always say
look it's important to have contrast
that's why you have clinical trials
right you have a control group so the
contrast matters so that you can you can
only verify that it's fake if you can
verify what is real and I understand
what you're saying it's tough to verify
what's real with any of these people but
here she is switching between accents or
affectations three times
in under 20 seconds wow
elections matter
there you go and when folks vote they
order what they want and in this case
they got what they asked for
[Applause]
I went off script a little bit I'm
and then she said it and Daddy
get and daddy gets the piece of fried
chicken
Chris she went into the difference
between black men and n-words and people
like is it Chris Rock no so we do have
an update
um on kumal Harris in Montreal Harris
and her sister moved uh to there with
her with their mother there uh to
Montreal Quebec
it's pronounced with McGill University
Affiliated Jewish General Hospital
and finally it's westbound it's right in
there
did he not say West Mountain pull it up
and finally Westmont High School
admonish hoodie it's pronounced it's
pronounced it's like did she go to West
Mount well her hobbies are walking on
the beach do you have it says Westmont
Michael they didn't highlight it for him
though so I'm admonishing the
researchers yes you're right there pops
Crowder I like the Jamaican part it
works better America yeah yes my
roommates in college for Jamaican does
that count I was in Jamaica and a guy
walked up I swear to God and said you
moved like a Jamaican and then I said
Thank you and I said I must move like a
Jamaican and then he gave me a joint I
paid him 20 and I smoked that joint and
then I had I I called the emergency
department
I'm not a smoker and I was like I can't
feel my feet yeah and I can't feel
myself breathing and then my girlfriend
well I take back the wisdom comment
because you're not a smoker but you
bought a joint for 20 from a strange
Jamaican in a bathroom I wanted them to
like me just because he comfortable plus
his hands were so strong and dark yeah
sorry that's from years of filling
Bonefish
when I went to Guantanamo Bay that was a
big thing Jamaicans there they loved it
was a Bonefish thing one of them stabbed
again Cubans what say bone again no they
were Jamaicans in Cuba in Cuba oh
Jamaicans in Cuba and Guantanamo a lot
of them would work there and he stabbed
the guy who uh took us out fishing with
a bone no he he stabbed him for I mean
he could have okay if you sharpen a bone
anyway Tim can do that now here is
Kamala Harris here's Kamala Harris even
code switching so we have
we have three times in 20 seconds and
now we have her code switching when
she's in France with us in government
we campaign with the plan
uppercase t uppercase P the plan
I don't know if that's the code
switching so much as just bombing yeah
yeah I was just about to say every time
she does it it makes her sound worse
which is at the feet yeah I'm not sure
how you sound worse than you already
sound Kamala but you didn't she was
wearing a mask and sometimes you have to
read someone's face for comedy but the V
never goes before a consonant
go before anything but but a vowel these
people don't speak English either yeah
I think it's just the benzos yeah
that adrenochrom Won't Suck Itself
joking right now you know
okay stop it smash the rumble button by
the way if you're watching right now
head on over to rumble what are you
doing here watch on Rumble I'm really
excited to get to the Bud Light segment
because that's fun that's a win and
today you know we're all in a good mood
because you can see the fruits of your
labor but before we get to that one more
Downer I apologize between the white
house uh Easter egg hunt and his trip to
Dublin Ireland or is Joe Biden
pronounces it no I'm not high Ireland
charms
and then Paul Harris like a child that
sees another kid gets a laugh goes yeah
yeah I too went to Dublin Ireland I've
always gone there as a child what smoke
I lie with you too I like to lie it
makes me feel big
any Mayors I can sleep with
ah Willie which brings us to this week
in Biden
if you have a problem
with you for me or Trump and you ain't
black are you saying that uh that you
would be uh taking part in uh our
upcoming election in 2014. I'll either
be rolling an egg or you know being the
the you know the guy who's pushed him
out come on help a brother out
[Music]
look at this Air Force One
all right if you have a problem figuring
out with you for me or Trump then you
ain't black was that a space shuttle
that he was holding up when he said Air
Force One I don't know but I have a
bunch of notes that don't make sense
he doesn't know where he is he doesn't
know that first one I didn't I I was
listening to I do news briefings where I
listen to them and I was even trying to
decipher what's he trying to say it's
worrisome because if he wins the next
election he'll be 86 in office 86. they
won't let him well you know what I think
yeah I think we should 86 that men's
vice president
come on now come on now admonish me
big words hold on Tim admonish means uh
you and Stephen all right imagine
he can admonish us too for this this
view-esque crosstalk today it's my fault
it's been fun it's been fun it's a fun
show hey hopefully you guys are okay
this is just this is a more relaxed show
today because it's a good day as a ice
cube or iced tea I get him confused I'm
no Kamala
so today was a good day that's Ice Cube
Ice Cube for sure it is but I'm going
with tea iced tea is the one who does
the ads for against domestic abuse and
car Shield yeah car Shield yeah which is
perfect for him because he was a pimp
right so he is the only one who should
be able to beat his from his
pimp car that's right and not fear an
engine going out car Shield is your is
your car covered you mean from theft
from people like you shut up
so Bud Light okay you guys know about
this from earlier this week but here's
kind of the lowdown um
and we always want to offer some
solutions here at this show because I
understand that a lot of you feel
helpless that's so much of the chat that
we get the questions are Hey What Can I
Do there's a lot that you can do and
there is we are kind of at a good point
I would say uh at this moment in history
because there are more local options
than than ever for almost all of these
giant multi-conglomerate Alternatives
now that's not going to change the
international markets and the ESG score
but as far as your day-to-day life it
can affect you zero and you can affect
the bottom line of these companies I
will say this I think that this
Budweiser this Bud Light uh is going to
go down like New Coke and Schlitz for
people who don't know let's bring that
up the researcher slits they were the
number one beer in the country at one
point a lot of you may not know this I
believe it was the 60s and they changed
their formulation to use hot pellets and
they lost ground to Budweiser and they
never gained it back I wish Schlitz was
available today actually if I'm gonna
drink one of those I I like Schlitz it's
not great but it's passable Bud Light
tastes like Satan's piss so yeah
I mean I assume uh
but here's it shows that boycotts to
some degree work but it's not just about
a boycott it there needs to be a
cultural movement okay so there needs to
be a cultural backlash and this is just
a big swing and a mess from Bud Light
them being so out of touch creates an
opening for all of you this is one thing
that we do sometimes when we'll do
whether it's to change my mind or we'll
plan for a segment we plan an argument
we plan a premise we go okay here's a
counter argument here's a counter
argument and then it's sort of like a
tree and then branches and then you
realize that there are certain people
they're not even past the stump and
that's the executives at Bud Light
that's the executives at Abercrombie and
Fitch right they're so out of touch they
can't know that they're out of touch so
this is the theme of this week let's
give you the then recap so then last
week uh Dylan Mulvaney
went viral if in case you've forgotten
receiving a Bud Light uh commemorative
can but then they confirmed that uh
Dylan Mulvaney that he was an ambassador
here's the clip
this month I celebrated my day 365 a
Womanhood and Bud Light Sent Me possibly
the best gift ever a can with my face on
it well I thought they were sent you a
gift of
it was on April fools too it's like
people didn't know if it was real yeah
Alex Jones thinks that Dylan Mulvaney is
a troll so then the uh that's a good
that's that makes sense to me that Andy
Kaufman thing yes I think John Mulvaney
has uh a great sense of humor and my
guess is this is a person just cashing
in come on let me see how far I can push
this I don't know but here's the thing
if this was think about if you did this
with race
when you're when you're again playing at
right we don't have to think about it we
have examples I mean and I'm and I'm
outraged but I'm on the show to be to
push back but um uh but if you were to
do this he's he's playing Womanhood it's
a it's kind of blackface yeah it's kind
of blackface for women it's much more
absurd when people came down to Rachel
dolezal I was saying look this is
actually far more reasonable than
claiming you can change your gender
there are far fewer differences
biologically between a black woman Zach
and a white woman than a woman black or
white and a man correct and here's the
strategy when you talk it's relevant
because the uh the marketing executive I
guess VP of marketing you know whatever
made up title uh they can create so that
a woman who's heading up a beer company
she has no business heading up can feel
important her name is Alyssa heiner
anyway
this was the explanation for the Dylan
Mulvaney decision and it's relevant
because that'll take us to now you've
got to see people who reflect you in the
work and we had this hangover I mean Bud
Light had been kind of a brand of shut
up body kind of out of touch humor and
it was really important she knows here
so I had this super clear Bandit it's
like we need to evolve and Elevate this
incredibly iconic brand and my what I
brought to that was a belief in okay
what is what is this mean it means
inclusivity it means Shifting the tone
it means having a campaign that's truly
inclusive and feels lighter and brighter
and different and appeals to women and
to men yeah
should include fixing split ends
um
I find her strangely attractive I do
want to feed her a sugar you're
disgusting yes nice salt what did I say
I'm not salt like your palm because they
bite your fingers so I want to represent
is it I thought horses got so much
whatever eat your oats they do she just
looks like she has a sweet tooth she
looks like if Amanda Pete had welcomed
an evil spirit into her I am not going
to disparage yeah yes you will uh we all
will peer pressure so there you go that
was the explanation and then someone
said what about beer she said beer so
this is what she does she decides to
represent women by uh putting a man on
the can and I know don't misconstrue
what I'm saying uh I mean um when I say
man I mean man
with all the tackle
oh
this brings us to now and please
everyone hit the like button right now
in celebration whether you're on YouTube
whether you're on Rumble announcer Bush
lost 6 billion dollars in market cap wow
I know you're saying that's not a lot
considering it's what 130 something
thousand million
thank you understand that right I was
not uh actually I didn't do the math but
that is six thousand million let me give
you an example it makes it sound less
impressive no no
so a million seconds a million seconds
11 days a billion seconds roughly 33
years
dollars yeah so that's insane can I have
a gun yes yeah it's a lot of them for
yourself yes for yourself just to be
clear and it means figuratively yeah I
just code switched to it because
petition yeah to an agent that's what it
was to an Asian oh that's this is where
I draw the line guys no it's not all
right fine
look behind you there's the line there
it is there
um gotta be on your feet on your toes
but Distributors by the way so not just
the market cap but here's part of the
trend again the trend line manners uh
matters you have the Distributors uh in
the south in the midwest right now of
Bud Light they reported uh dramatically
dwindling sales over uh Easter weekend
there was even a bar in Hell's Kitchen
which is very gay
they saw sales in New York dropped 58
that's fantastic by the way I love it
host kitchen is a gay area just because
it used to be you know the village then
I moved to Chelsea then Hell's Kitchen
is uh very largely you know practicing
homosexual and they don't want you it's
it's surprising that most people don't
celebrate the the Risen Christ with a
bud yes
well that's what they put on the sponge
just to mine
got the crown of thorns you're feeding
me Bud Light on a sponge what is it
let's get at this all right forgive them
they know not what not the Bud Light
I can't forgive that yeah he's just a
thief in the cross like well I well will
I be there with you in heaven what do
you say
you said who makes this it's terrible so
by the way uh not to be out done running
interference this is after the six
billion loss CNN still ran a story
defending the campaign saying Bud
light's inclusive uh ad campaigns are
good for business experts say wow
yeah if you don't go by things like uh
sales
a market cap
[Laughter]
um all the investors who just lost a
bunch of money are like yeah this is
great yeah this is great for us and
here's you know this is a this is a
smart move when you think about it it's
uh ignore at least 50 percent of the
country to go after uh less than half of
a percentage point because here's
something that you need to understand
about this uh I think it's what they say
1.6 of the population is transgender but
a huge portion of that huge portion of
that by the way 1.6 that's what they say
that's not true no it's all people who
identify as genderqueer and a huge
portion of one in five and gen Z
identify that way yeah it's social
contagious of course it is but my point
is even if you take that number now
subtract the vast majority of whom are
gen Z who aren't 21 how many transgender
21 year olds would even be interested in
drinking Bud Light it's about six
yeah but you've turned off everyone who
goes to NASCAR and bull riding and
country music so this will go down as
one of the greatest blunders I think oh
my God it's unbelievable you wonder if a
Malcolm Gladwell would write a book
about this tip for sure uh you know that
social contagion idea that this is it
would be just the Tipping Point that's
right that's right but people who cut
their own hair don't drink Budweiser
well it would be cutting off the Tipping
points yeah so it'd be cutting off so it
could even make the case would he dare
even make the case that this is Puma
they teach the Schlitz debacle uh they
would teach that in business classes in
college this is a major misstep like
people don't understand something like
this can really lead to the downfall
because it gives some somebody like
Yingling an opportunity to kind of step
into this space right and say okay well
we'll take that market share and then it
helps propel them also by the way
Yingling return we've reached out to
them for a sponsorship because like you
guys wouldn't be able to keep it on the
shelves
that the thing is I I worry that um
people forget so so with uh Netflix with
Disney it actually didn't no I did with
Disney it did for a second
is that right I thought they were back
up
that had that had to do with other
factors I think no you're wrong no I
think it's all you're incorrect you're
incorrect Brian why are you trying to
write on their print no it's down
where's the line it's down it's down
it's down but I do agree with your point
because I once had someone in uh and
this is something you got to get out of
the identity politics people on the
right I was in Michigan Michigan is one
of the best beer States uh in the
country and I had a guy who well you
know this this uh Tavern where we would
often go yes and he was kind of like a
trump voting uh sort of Republican and I
would have a local beer and you would
say I just drink Bud Light and I said
why is I said because that is made by
Americans and I said in the brewery
that's literally four miles down the
road isn't because a lot of you had to
say I drive a Ford truck that's actually
less made in America than than a lot of
Toyota cars just to be clear so what you
have to stop doing is thinking okay
identity Politics on the right like you
know I drink I put mustard on my fries
I'm country well he's Country Harley
Davidson no it's not an American
institution it's crap right it's just
it's a it's a rattle box between your
legs that you're spending eight times
the amount for Bud Light sure they've
marketed themselves as an All-American
company it's a lie it's a lie just like
you see from the left when they try and
fake like they're black or Indian or
Jamaican or Puerto Rican whatever it is
but here's the hypocrisy too again the
rule of contrast that's the theme of
today's show then and now a timeline
that's valuable by the way call us to
the madness check out the timeline here
check out how long we've been doing this
show check out me with the blue bed
sheet I I my growth has been stunted for
a very long time so
this executive
was busted at frat parties at frat style
parties here are leaked College photos
right now by the way and she's even
there Downing some beers unfortunately
it's rolling rock oh God
it's college and here she is blowing up
condoms
well that's
nothing like wishful thinking love
I think they were drinking shots out of
condoms yes you would know yeah
because I can read Yakuza I'm gay yeah
let's go with that so my question to you
is how many so as your lips were moving
you hit that that button and it it was
perfect how many drinks would you need
to uh find Alyssa heinershine um
suitable and it is free mug Club month
for another week live with credit.com
mug Club
do again consider joining up because
there's no way that we can support
ourselves through YouTube of course and
here's something though the solutions
here look
first there are a few different layers
to this okay
Budweiser out of business and by the way
for the record go check out
Anheuser-Busch and their entire catalog
yeah it's not just Bud Light and that's
something like Brian's Point some people
like I don't drink Bud Light and then
they go and they drink Corona whatever
it is they go and drink I don't know if
it's Becks or all these brands that they
have under the house you need to be
aware of what it is that you're
supporting look you need to okay not
purchase products actively actively
oppose companies who hate everything you
stand for but you need to contrast that
by actively supporting companies who
actually share your values and here's
the beauty of it it's never been more
easy than today for example you'll never
see television ratings that use Johnny
Carson we've talked about that right the
fracturing of viewership which is why
we're so grateful for you tuning in
because people have more choices you
have more choices it's never been easier
to both boycott and boycott if you don't
want to drink Bud Light and you want to
drink a a watered-down macro urine
logger all you need to do is
tilt your head slightly or I guess I
should say pan it slightly to the right
and grab another case of crap or if you
want to try something better just go a
little bit more to the right and you
will have 50 choices from local uh you
have distillers you have local Brewers
and also understand local doesn't
necessarily mean you're safe there are
plenty of local woke crap Brewers yeah
just takes a little bit of research we
do this all the time even before I buy a
product I'll just look online at about
us I go uh rainbow flag let me go find
their alternative just do some research
you can and this starts with your
community it starts with supporting
local businesses who aren't beholden to
International influence who aren't
concerned about the ESG scores these
issues these indexes we should probably
do a refresher course on that maybe next
week it's not about you the customer
it's about appealing to International
investors it's about mitigating this
risk here's the thing at a certain point
though when they become so unprofitable
or irrelevant guess what the market
might have to correct itself to a degree
we're not going to get back where we
were before but the good news is we
don't have to you can have your own
Community there are so many choices out
there I see people going what are we
switching to Coors Light it's not like
it's just Bud Light Of course lighter
Mill or like Budweiser so many options
and it's not like you have to sacrifice
a ton of quality either in this case
it'd actually be better
exactly I was about to say local
breweries are everywhere yes and I think
that these corporations there's this
idea these they're these powerful
monoliths and they are but they're not
principled right and they do respond to
the bottom line and you can have a huge
effect yeah you can yeah and it can last
but you've gotta like to your point you
better you've got to educate yourself we
are no longer at a point in my opinion
where you can afford to be
politically ignorant yep and and
politically non-committed because if you
are you're part of the problem and
that's just a fact no I agree with you
it used to be like you know what I don't
go into politics at all and I don't know
there's a on it I can't right yeah
in the 20th century by the way when you
were like ah yeah I'm not into politics
it's every single inch that you have to
fight for and that's why we're happy to
have people like you here happy to have
people like Nick de Paul here we're
happy to be bringing on other people who
are actually risking something not
people who are just making money off of
you as conservatives but people who have
been in this industry for a long time
yeah you will get blacklisted yes your
career will suffer as a result and we
want to be able to have your back but
you cannot afford to just ignore
politics doesn't mean that you have to
follow it uh every second of the day
that's why we try and offer you this
show what you do is you have an hour and
a half to two hours where you can tune
in every day Monday through Friday 10
a.m Eastern and then we make the
references available so you can decide
you
want in studying these issues and I
encourage you to and I encourage you
LeVar Burton don't take my word for it
take the word of this six-year-old with
a pop-up book but here's the thing Bud
light's marketing team is clearly
struggling uh and um you know it does
seem like some other competitors uh have
picked up the ball yeah yeah
and they're doing a little bit of
In-House production advertising it's an
opportunity Stephen what would if your
beer tastes like water and has gone
completely flaccid it's mug clubbed
foreign
[Music]
I think they hit the they hit the dump
button sorry if you're on YouTube I
don't know when we're back but obviously
here on Rumble you can watch we're about
to say there Brian I'm so sorry I
stepped on that no it's okay
no expense what would white have to do
to get back into your good graces make
good beer I don't know seppuku I didn't
have to think about it all right well
that's uh that's about it they can't
that's the problem I mean
some of their spokespeople
yeah but there should be there should be
a path to Stephen the odds are in your
favor on that one don't worry
Brian wait I couldn't
I thought oh well the answer is thank
God we hit the YouTube there's nothing
that they could do they pandered they
went the wrong direction if they come
back it's only because it financially
hurts it's not because they actually
change their mind and it's all the air
of their ways so no no
[Music]
foreign
okay
oh boy
what could go wrong there
so yesterday uh the uh columnist by the
way uh Carey Sheffield
um really took it to Joy Reed on Joy
reads show she still has one
surprisingly and gave her history lesson
and by the way we've actually done a
video on this on Margaret Sanger and
written articles at ladder with
crowder.com so um we'll probably have
the link somewhere where you can click
it uh more in depth I highly recommend
that you learn about the roots of
Planned Parenthood but uh Carey
Sheffield actually educated Joy Reed who
you would think would know the roots of
an intensely racist organization
considering how obsessed she is with you
know fictional racism uh so they
discussed the roots of abortion I
believe in human rights I to me abortion
is as evil as slavery it truly is and
when you look at the founding of Planned
Parenthood and who Margaret Sanger was
you look at her research she was a woman
who believed in Eugenics she was a woman
who believed in the purification of the
race and she didn't want certain women
to reproduce but I find that Legacy to
be deeply problematic from just a
scientific stand right but the vast
majority of women are not eugenicists
most people probably don't even know who
Marcus Sanger is most women just want
control of their own body first off why
is she wearing a sea urchin on her head
no way actually who wore it better uh
Joy Reed or uh me as Tom York actually
but don't you love the little argument
she makes most women are not eugenesis
sure but you believe that people who by
the way are uh descendants from uh free
non-slave states who never had slave
holders in their past oh reparations
we're only talking about a couple of
generations removed uh where this was a
proactive Eugenics approach yeah but
most women aren't that well I'm not a
slave owner no and I don't
understand but the Democrats went from
safe legal and rare that was the the
rare part up front you guys never
thought this even you never thought that
this should be as widespread as it is
right now especially when it was she
said certain women not reproducing it
was uh imbeciles but mostly black people
that's why they put the clinics in Black
communities yes so that they could make
sure that there were less black babies
so that they would have less black
people in the country because she was a
racist yep there goes all those votes
well it doesn't matter because they uh
they're building the world in their
image think about it you control
population you destroy the family and
then you create you sow Division I mean
this is the Playbook this is this is the
fascist Playbook by the way fascism a
distinctly extreme left ideology if you
guys actually want to understand because
Consolidated power to uh the government
but Monday sorry to interrupt but it's
also important of a history lesson with
the Communist Revolution the Bolshevik
Revolution the idea was that the state
would raise your child that you know it
was very Bourgeois to have parents a
mother raiser child you can see your
kids but let the state because we have
experts who know how to raise your child
so there was an attack on the nuclear
family yep uh and that was that was
Central to Marx's thinking and it's and
it's uh it's also uh sort of exemplified
by it takes a village it's like well no
hold on a second no The Village helps
yes Village helps it's good to have a
community the community is that you've
uh proactively sought to destroy but it
takes a family and you don't want that
to be a component it's incredibly
important that's why by the way that's
why we have marriage laws that's why we
have tax incentives on the books because
our founding father said before there
was any kind of federal governance
before State governance before even
Municipal governance there needs to be
self-governance and that can only take
place with strong families but not to
understand this on Monday uh former Vice
President Joe Biden uh said April 11th
through April 17th
is black maternal Health week whatever
so black maternal Health that week is
the week I I celebrate uh White paternal
wealth yeah I would say I celebrate
White Bear and womb so I'm busy it's
like a Wednesday to a Wednesday Joe why
yeah because it's like a Tuesday night
idea yeah well thank god he's on it well
he black women must feel so safe
what happened to Sunday you gave him the
leap year of weeks Biden I mean you're
no math Asian that is seven days all
right whatever you and your Spanish
accents in your mouth hey you started
this crap with your grammar so Biden
called upon Americans to amplify the
voices and experiences of black women
families and communities and committing
to building a world in which black women
do not have to fear for their safety hey
how about the black babies who are more
likely to be aborted in New York
right the most dangerous place for them
to be is in their mother's womb so
they're by the way about 20 million
black people who won't be um celebrating
it just to be clear uh or anything ever
uh because 20 million black lives have
been ended through abortion including
women and girls from 2019 to 2020
abortion rates among black women Rose
from 386 to 426 per thousand live births
and experts say it would have been even
higher if R Kelly wasn't convicted
I need to see a data on that I'm sorry
yeah I don't have it
well I'll get a six-year-old with a
pop-up but you don't have to take my
word for it okay
reading rain though
the Planned Parenthood is the worst
thing to happen to black baby since
Madonna let's just be clear about it
and we all want to sit here and act like
oh yeah black women they don't care
about you understand if they don't they
only use you when convenient and people
say this is race no I'm they fake your
voice and I mean they fake black boys
they think you'll actually buy it by
maternal Health they mean killing your
babies but it's genocide it was set up
as a genocidal organization to be clear
and it was done through subversive
methods and by the way this also brings
us into something that a lot of you may
have a tough time navigating I don't
want to spend too much time on this but
you've probably heard about the abortion
pill right being outlawed and then as it
outlers it not so last night there was a
federal appeals court they ruled that
this abortion pill um Memphis pristine
could remain available I believe it was
a court uh that sort of blocked the
block from Texas to be clear it just
can't be sent in the mail the decision
overruled in yeah Northern District of
Texas judge who last week's The Food and
Drug administration's approval Bill
Prestone uh in 2000 was not valid in
essence uh he was saying that the drug
should be pulled from the market so it's
about a safety issue care about as it
relates to drugs see the MRNA injection
but just to be clear the abortion pill
that we're talking about here is not the
same as Plan B I just want to be clear
because that's what the left tries to
say where it's like the morning after
pill and then they they try and
extrapolate from now they go they want
to ban all contraception they want to
make it so you can't get a 25 cent
rubber at a truck stop no there actually
are safety issues and again the law of
contrast the way that it went through
the process with the
[Music]
thank you
agree with either or not yeah absolutely
I can't remember what state it was maybe
the researchers can get it for us it was
either it was one of the West coast
states bought a bunch of it right to
make sure that it was going to be
available for their citizens and people
could come and get it from them I'm like
oh that's that's what you should be
spending your money on by the way no
matter what state it was Washington
Oregon or California they have better
things to do with the money trust me
we've we've seen what those States look
like those policies lead to so but
they're they're making sure that that
kind of stat that we showed from New
York like that's that's heartbreaking
right oh they're talking about it on CNN
right now let's see if they conflate the
two right now on CNN nothing else and
that's 23 years and we should also note
that that's as a result of the FDA
approval the Federal Drug Administration
that is the entity that really examines
whether or not something should be
brought to Market in making that
assessment they found the FDA did that
it was perfectly fine and proper now we
have a district court judge the lower
court but here's the thing explain as we
just did explain why some people may not
agree with you and then address the
argument instead they just go the FDA
said it's fine sure we've already heard
that there are some people saying the
process wasn't as valid as other FDA
processes they don't even address it
they're going with talking point number
one of course there and and by the way
you want to you want to just kind of
appeal to the authority of the FDA right
that that argument uh we'll pull some
examples of some of the things that the
fda's approved that you know maybe they
would want that one back right and by
the way I also understand that the
problem is some drugs that would help
you are not approved by the FDA they're
sitting on the shelf because they might
cause tummy discomfort I think that you
should be able to use experimental
medication if you understand the risks
and you you make that decision for
yourself I don't think that there should
be some bureaucratic organization that
beyond the basic Realms of safety should
prevent you from access to to some
Health Care out there this is not that
when we're talking about especially
something in some instances is taxpayer
funded so you can't have it both ways
when you have the left for years
remember it was all it was all the
Patchouli wearing granola hippies saying
oh man Pharma I wish that I loved
anything as much as the Democrat Party
loves a big Pharma these days anything
seems they have changed their ways just
so I could feel alive
that's cutting they really yes yes
that's true but the Hot Topic can't
let's see what else he's saying here and
we're going to be continuing on Rumble
not on YouTube as we do some stuff up
but I want to see what they're saying
yeah uniformity yeah right everyone
wants you need consistency in life you
need to know what the rules are what the
benchmarks are what's happening next and
so I think when you have this level
consistency like male female this fifth
Circuit Court you need the Supreme Court
to interpret that it doesn't mean their
interpretation is going to get any
better it's very conservative right six
justices
it's gonna get any better it's still
very conservative that right there just
showed you he fancies himself an
objective journalist right now the
Supreme Court here's what he just said
the Supreme Court is bad because it
represents half the country that I
disagree with
the most trusted name in news
it's better as a is a qualitative term
yes right oh they're conservative that's
why I'm sorry why would that matter
because the other ones are are liberal
by your definition you're splitting it
so there is a liberal so it's just who
you agree with exactly the actual law or
the actual process by the way it's
California they have secured to because
California doesn't have other problems
yeah they don't have a 20 billion dollar
deficit they don't they need to buy a
bunch of pills 250
000 pills and they're negotiating for up
to two million more because
people need to be able to kill their
babies babies in California is there
there's a difference between uh the
abortion bill in Plan B yeah there's a
morning after pill and again you do have
some people who disagree they say
actually it kind of it can disrupt the
uterine well kind of like some people
talk about iuds it can actually irritate
the uterine wall post uh post uh
fertilization
um but still there the plan B is not the
same as actually like the abortion pill
which basically dissolves uh what is
already existing there did I just say it
because it's not no one and I understand
that there are arguments to be made on
that on that topic that's not what I'm
doing right now what I'm telling you is
that is not even on the table what we
are talking about is the abortion pill
which can be taken a significantly later
amount of time that no one disagrees
right on the right or left is in fact an
abortion so they don't care anyway good
right they don't care anyway
here's if I am let me just leave you
with this okay and and please do we're
going to go to to mug Club here and we
have a Casey's gag reflex and chat
Thursday and there's a lot of chat
regarding perhaps sitting down with the
uh some people say former president some
people say sitting president Donald
Trump I say sitting president okay
they'll be talking about that in chat
Thursday but while we're discussing
um abortion here you know I don't know I
don't even know I want to go into this I
don't even know if we have time we've
already gone over time
what do you think
piss off tell him to piss off yeah you
know what I just I'm so glad we have the
YouTube dump button but it's it's free
mug Club months I'm going to continue
this here right now on Rumble if you're
on YouTube what the hell are you doing
here just help the algorithm if you want
I don't care whatever head on over to
rumble we're going to continue for
another 45 minutes here with stuff that
we could never say on YouTube
thank you